Prince Harry and Megan Markel take their  love on Safari  [Music]  thirty two-year-old royal and his  ladylove jetted off to South Africa over  the weekend to celebrate Megan's 36th  birthday with a regal African safari  [Music]  couple was spotted exiting a plane  smiling and in seemingly great spirits  donning casual attire Megan in jeans and  a tank while Harry rocked jeans and a  plaid button down the pair wore matching  baseball caps and sunny Harry had his  arm draped around the suit star and even  gave a thumbs-up to be on lookers  according to the son Harry and Megan are  expected to be on safari but will also  enjoy a boat trip and camping out during  their stay